>> Greg: YOU'LL WANT TO HIT
THE MUTE WHEN THEY BRING ON THE
DEMON AND A PANTSUIT.
WITH ELECTION HOPES ONE EVENING,
HILLARY IS COMPLAINING.
THE JOYLESS JOY REID WELCOMED
HILLARY CLINTON TO HER
HORRENDOUS SHOW AND CLINTON WAS
IN FULL G.O.P. BASHING MODE JUST
LIKE THE GOOD OLD DAYS WHEN BILL
WAS ACCUSED OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
AND HILLARY ROAMED THE HALLS
LIKE SHE HULK AND A PANTSUIT.
TOO BAD SHE'S GOT LESS MATERIAL
THAN A THIRD EYE BLIND COVER
BAND.
LIKE ANY TIRED ACT SHE STUCK TO
HER GREATEST HITS WITHOUT
PLAYING ANY NEW STUFF.
MAY BE HER NEW TUNES GOT WIPED
CLEAN ON THAT SERVER.
I WONDER IF THERE HAS BEEN A
STREAK OF VIOLENCE OF RACISM,
MISOGYNY, ANTI-SEMITISM.
>> THERE HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
STREAK OF VIOLENCE, OF RACISM,
MISOGYNY, ANTI-SEMITISM THROWN
INTO VERY HIGH RELIEF BY THE
HORRIFIC ATTACK ON PAUL PELOSI.
IT'S NOT JUST AN ABERRATION
WHERE ONE OR TWO PEOPLE OVER A
SMALL GROUP ENGAGE IN THAT KIND
OF VIOLENT RHETORIC AND URGE
PEOPLE TO TAKE ACTION AGAINST
POLITICAL FIGURES, WE ARE SEEING
A WHOLE POLITICAL PARTY.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT BEN
FRANKLIN.
I KNOW THIS IS WHAT ABOUTISM BUT
YOU MURDER PEOPLE.
I KID, YOU KNOW THE DEMOCRATS
ARE GETTING DESPERATE WHEN THERE
FORCED TO TROT OUT THIS TUB OF
BITTER PUTTY A WEEK BEFORE
MIDTERMS.
LATER HILLARY DROPPED WHAT FELT
LIKE AN UPDATE TO HER BASKET OF
DEPLORABLES COMMENTS FOR 2016
WHICH DID SO WELL FOR HER,
LISTEN TO THIS NONSENSE AFTER
JOY REID ASKED HILLARY IF SHE
THINKS PEOPLE GRASP WHAT A
G.O.P. TAKEOVER CONGRESS WOULD
MEAN.
>> I DON'T THINK PEOPLE ARE ABLE
TO REALLY GRASP THAT BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY I'M NOT SURE THEY
REALLY UNDERSTAND THE THREATS TO
THEIR WAY OF LIFE.
THEY MAY THINK WHOEVER IS
CHAIRING A COMMITTEE IS KIND OF
ABSTRACT.
>> Greg: SHE MAKES NAILS ON A
CHALKBOARD SOUND LIKE BEETHOVEN.
IF ONLY THERE WAS A DRUG THAT
LET YOU BLOCK HEARING HER VOICE
EVER AGAIN I WOULD TOTALLY TAKE
IT.
>> THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN A STREAK
OF VIOLENCE, OF RACISM,
MISOGYNY, ANTI-SEMITISM.
>> DOES SHE EVER GO AWAY?
>> WISHING YOU CAN WATCH TV
WITHOUT THE IRRITATED SCREECHES
OF HILLARY CLINTON?
DO I?
NOW YOU CAN, INTRODUCING A
ONE-OF-A-KIND PILL DESIGNED TO
BLOCK OUT HER INCESSANT
DIATRIBES ONCE AND FOR REAL NOW
INSTEAD OF ENDLESS COMPLAINING
ABOUT THE G.O.P. YOU'LL HEAR
SOUNDS THAT ARE INFINITELY MORE
PLEASING TO THE HUMAN EAR.
GO AHEAD, TRY IT, THEY ARE IN
YOUR POCKET.
>> HOW DO THESE GET IN HERE?
>> LET'S NOT WORRY ABOUT THAT,
GIVE IT A SHOT.
♪ ♪
>> WHILE, BLUEGRASS!
>> PRETTY COOL, TAKE TWO PILLS
AND YOU WILL HEAR SOMETHING
ELSE.
>> HERE'S YOUR NFL SCORES FOR
WEEK EIGHT, THE EAGLES TOOK DOWN
THE STEELERS 35-13 WHILE THE
BILLS BEST OF THE PACKERS 27-17.
AMAZING!
I LOVED UP TO THE DATE SPORTS
SCORES I'M GOING TO TAKE THREE
NOW.
>> IT DOESN'T MEAN HILLARY
WOULD'VE BEEN A GOOD CHOICE, SHE
WAS A TERRIBLE CHOICE, SHE'S A
CORRUPT POLITICIAN ONE THE MOST
UNLIKABLE PEOPLE WHO HAS EVER
RUN FOR OFFICE.
>> JOE ROGAN PODCAST IT'S
MESSING WITH MY VISION TOO?
>> THE EFFECT IS DIFFERENT FOR
EVERYONE.
>> I'VE HAD LIKE SIX PILLS IS
THAT SAFE?
>> NO IDEA BUT AT LEAST HE WON'T
HERE HILLARY ANYMORE.
TRIED TODAY.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: IS THIS SOUR GRAPES
TOUR TURNING INTO I'LL SAY
ANYTHING TO GET ATTENTION?
>> IT'S HARDER TO PAY ATTENTION,
I DON'T EVEN NEED THAT PILL
BECAUSE WHEN SHE WAS TALKING I
ZONED OUT.
I SHOULD NOT HAVE DONE THAT
BECAUSE THE STUFF SHE WAS SAYING
SOUNDS SCARY.
NOBODY SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT
THE END OF LIFE AS WE KNOW IT
AND THE END OF DEMOCRACY THE END
OF OUR FREEDOM AND I'M LIKE
WHATEVER.
I SHOULD NOT BE HAVING THAT
RESPONSE BUT I AM BECAUSE SHE'S
BEEN SAYING THIS FOR SO LONG,
THIS IS ALL SHE HAS BEEN SAYING
FOR YEARS AND IT HASN'T
HAPPENED.
THE CLOSE TAKES EXAMPLE I GUESS
WOULD BE JANUARY 6TH WHICH
DIDN'T WORK.
>> Greg: IT'S TRUE, I THINK
SHE BELIEVES THIS IS HOW SHE
MAINTAINS A SHRED OF RELEVANCE.
>> I DON'T KNOW I WOULD RATHER
BE FORGOTTEN.
SHE GOES ON THERE, SHE CAN'T
EVEN COMMIT TO THE ACT ANYMORE.
I THINK SHE'S TIRED AND SHE'S
TRYING TO GET MORE BOOKINGS AND
THE ONLY ONE CALLING AS
JOY REID, IT'S EITHER THIS OR
THE VIEW.
SHE'S RUNNING OUT OF SPOTS.
WHEN YOU SAY THINGS LIKE THEIR
IS A SMIDGE -- WHAT IS THAT SIX
PEOPLE -- WE HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
[BLEEP] IN THE G.O.P. AND THAT'S
IT?
I THINK THAT'S A GOOD NUMBER, IF
THERE'S 66 GUYS WHO WE SAY NO,
YOU STAY HERE, WE ARE GOING TO
GO FIX THE COUNTRY, YOU STAY
WORKING ON THE TRUCKS, WE GOT
YOU.
SHE CAN'T PUT THE NUMBERS OUT
THERE LIKE THERE IS THIS GIANT
MOB JUST ROAMING EVERYWHERE,
DOING BAD STUFF LIKE GOING TO
WORK, PAYING TAXES AND WANTED
THEIR CHILDREN TO HAVE GOOD
EDUCATION.
YOU'VE GOT TO WATCH THEM,
DRESSING UP THEIR TRUCKS WITH
AMERICAN FLAGS, WHAT IS THE
WORLD COMING TO?
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE AT
LITTLE LEAGUE BASEBALL GAMES,
WHAT?
>> IS THERE SOUR GRAPES, THIS
MAKES YOU LOOK PRETTY
SUCCESSFUL.
>> SHE DOES COME I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK HER FOR THAT.
IS IT JUST ME -- SHE'S TELLING
PEOPLE THEY ARE STUPID, YOU
CAN'T GRASP THIS, SHE CAN'T
GRASP OF THE MOISTURIZER.
I'M SORRY, IT'S HARD TO WATCH,
IS THIS ALL THEY HAVE?
I FEEL LIKE IF WE HAD SEEN
VIDEOS OF THIS YEARS AGO IF WE
HAD SEEN WHAT SHE WAS REALLY
LIKE I FEEL LIKE WHEN THE
MONICA LEWINSKY THING HAPPENED
WE WOULD'VE BEEN LIKE BILL, WE
GET IT.
>> Greg: YOU ARE NODDING ALONG
TO WHAT OUR SO-CALLED COMEDIAN
WAS SAYING.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANYTHING!
IT'S SO OBVIOUS.
>> BY THE WAY, HILLARY, I WANT
HER TO BE GONE SHE'S BEEN AROUND
POLITICS FOREVER.
I'M SURE SHE'S GOT ENOUGH MONEY,
SHE EMBEZZLED ENOUGH MONEY OUT
OF US OVER THE YEARS SHE COULD
LIVE A VERY NICE LIFE PLAYING IN
THE FOURTH QUARTER SHE NEEDS TO
WORK ON HER HAIR AND MAKEUP, IT
JUST WASN'T WORKING.
AFTER LISTENING TO HER IT LOOKS
LIKE IF THE REPUBLICANS TAKE THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE THE WAY SHE
IS TALKING, WE'RE ALL GOING TO
DIE.
IT'S OVER WITH BUT IT'S NICE TO
KNOW WE ARE GOING TO DIE FROM
THE REPUBLICANS -- AOC SAID WE
WERE GOING TO DIE IN 12 YEARS
LIKE WE HAVE ABOUT THREE MORE
YEARS BEFORE WE ARE ALL GOING TO
DIE FROM CLIMATE CHANGE.
WERE ALL GOING TO DIE.
>> Greg: SO WHY NOT GO WITH
THE REPUBLICANS?
YOU'LL HAVE MORE MONEY IN THE
BA